[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATT DUFTLER: All
right, welcome.
Thank you all for coming.
My name is Matt Duftler.
I'm a software engineer
with Google in New York.
I'm really excited
to be here with Tom
from Waze, Andy from Wetflick--
Netflix.
It was close.
Talk to you all about Spinnaker.
We've all been working
together for a few years,
but it's nice to
have a good reason
to get together in the
same place once in a while.
So I'm just going to
be here for a minute.
I'm going introduce
Tom and Andy,
and then I'll be
back in a while.
I told my wife we
were doing this talk
and I wanted to come
up with a Waze joke
to give Tom a hard time.
And she tried to talk me out of
it, said I should just be nice.
And then we were thinking
we can let Tom come up
and get into it, and
then every time he's
just about to the
interesting part,
I'll just loudly interrupt him
to warn him of a car up ahead,
or a mattress on the highway,
or the cops, or something.
But I won't.
So I'll be back in a
little bit, talk to you
a lot about what Google's
doing with Spinnaker.
And for now, here's Tom.
[APPLAUSE]
TOM FEINER: Thanks, Matt.
Thanks, Matt.
In 2008, a small startup
called Waze was formed.
We hit the ground
running with a mission
to help our users
outsmart traffic together.
To achieve that mission, we
needed very fast feedback
from our users.
How did we get it?
We ship software features,
and we ship them fast.
We did that using a few
developers deploying
to a few physical servers.
However, we couldn't scale
on physical hardware.
So then we moved to the cloud.
Once we were in the
cloud, things really
started getting complicated.
Till now, the developers
were able to deploy software
to production on their own.
But as the amount
of users grew, we
had to start using
autoscaling massively,
until we ended up with
hundreds of autoscaling groups
and thousands of instances.
The more we grew,
the more severe
the problem became,
until eventually,
the entire development
team lost this capability
to deliver software
to production.
It simply evaporated.
And that was mainly
due to lack of tooling.
Back then, to deploy one
backend service to production,
developers needed
to create images,
deploy them to
multiple geographically
charted autoscaling groups,
usually in a rolling fashion.
And rollbacks were
extremely painful.
So this job moved
to the SRE team,
which is in charge
of Waze production.
But at least we
were able to grow.
So we started out with a goal
of fast feedback from our users.
But as we hit a certain scale
of Waze users, developers,
and microservices,
the complexity
of software deployment
went up dramatically.
So things were kind
of grinding to a halt.
There was this bottleneck,
but nobody really
realized just how bad it was.
Once developers couldn't ship
as fast as they wanted to,
they started batching features
into the same release.
And it became riskier to
deploy like that to production.
Even though they
wanted to ship fast
once features were completed,
they simply could not.
And because of the batching
of features and bug fixes,
releases became extremely large.
And it's nasty to
work like this,
because by now,
you are deploying
very large pieces of software
that could break the system.
And when it breaks,
it's not clear
which one of the 10
features just released
caused the problem.
So solving it
becomes much harder.
From the SRE team
perspective, the team
is working like crazy
to ship software,
but it's never enough.
So everybody's disappointed
and there's a ton of pressure.
From a user's perspective,
features arrive slowly,
and the system could
definitely be more stable.
So we looked for solutions.
Lucky for us, Netflix
was gracious enough
to share both their
experience and the software
they've built to solve this
problem, which is Spinnaker.
So what exactly is Spinnaker?
Well, it's an open source,
multi-cloud, continuous
delivery platform for
deploying, releasing,
software changes with high
velocity and confidence.
So for us, Spinnaker is
essentially a shortcut
to achieving what we want.
And what we want is fast,
safe, and repeatable software
delivery with easy rollbacks.
So we deployed
Spinnaker throughout all
of the development
teams at Waze.
And this is how reality changed.
As a developer, I now have
the feedback cycle I need.
Because right now,
deployments are back
to a single click operation.
And it's all self-service.
I can ship.
I can get feedback.
And the core of the matter is
that I have complete autonomy.
And because I have
complete autonomy,
I don't need to rely on
the SRE team anymore,
which are now free to
work on system stability
and scalability,
which is a good thing.
So we have-- oh, sorry.
And the best part is that our
users get features and bug
fixes much quicker.
So we have happier users.
And because we're shipping
smaller amounts of features
each time, the risk of
service disruption goes down.
And when there is a problem,
solving it becomes much easier.
When you see the immediate
feedback of your work
and have complete
autonomy, it gives you
more drive and motivation to go
even quicker, take more risks,
and transform the service
to be even more amazing.
So that explains things
on a super high level.
If we drill down,
Spinnaker's power
really comes from its
abstraction and powerful
pipeline engine.
It allows us to bridge between
multiple technology stacks.
In our case, VMs and
Kubernetes and cloud providers.
Its a sweet spot between
just the amount of
abstraction on top
of each technology,
but it is still able to
control each stack precisely.
That's a bit contradictory,
but Spinnaker somehow
manages to pull it off.
Once applications
are using Spinnaker,
everybody in the company has
this single pane of glass
which can be used to perform
the daily work of deploying
software.
And the main point is that
it feels the same no matter
what technology
stack you are on,
whether you are on
VMs, Kubernetes,
App Engine, or any cloud
provider supported.
So life was good, for a while.
As you well know, when
you solve one problem,
two new problems are created,
and they were created.
One of them was managing
this crazy amount
of pipelines in production.
And the other was that
we were moving too fast.
Now, we wanted to move fast,
so why is that a problem?
Well, it's a problem
because its risky,
and we'll get to
that in a moment.
So by now, we had over
1,000 deployments pipelines
in production.
All of them were managed
through the Spinnaker UI.
And it became a huge pain
point for the teams to operate,
because each of these
pipelines were essentially
duplicates of one another, with
slight changes in between them.
So for example, adding a stage
to all of these productions
pipelines is too much of
a risk for production.
There's actually no
one willing to do it.
So we started looking
for solutions.
And the idea was to build a
paved road deployment pipeline.
Something that 80% of
the development teams
could use and be happy
with, while the rest of them
could change it and adapt it to
their needs, but still use it.
What happened in the
past was that each team
had their own set of pipelines.
And when they had a good idea,
it remained local to that team.
Now, with the paved
road pipeline templates,
these changes are
done centrally.
So all of these ideas
and best practices
are available throughout
the entire company.
So we started off with a
simple paved road pipeline.
It has a bake, a
smoke test, or stage,
and deploy to production.
Each car represents one specific
version of an application.
Now, from the
animation, you can see
that what used to be 1,000
separate pipelines are now all
using this paved road pipeline.
And this encapsulates
the best practices
we know of how to deliver
software to production.
And it has also finally
become manageable.
Remember that problem
of moving too fast?
Well, this change essentially
raised the speed limit
of the company from 60 miles
an hour to 600 miles an hour.
And when you do that,
new risks will appear.
Now, we wanted to move
extremely fast, but it's risky.
So we needed more safeguards.
In order to solve this problem,
we added a canary stage.
We evolved our
paved road pipeline.
Let's see how it looks.
[LAUGHTER]
So now she's checking
each version and deciding.
OK.
To do that, we simply duplicated
the previous paved road
pipeline, add in a
canary stage, which
Matt will talk about
later in depth,
and then sent one
of the applications
to the new paved road
pipeline, tested it.
And once we were happy,
we disabled the old one
and sent everybody
to the new road.
So by now, developers
woke up one morning
and had an option for a
safer deployment pipeline.
They could now move from
a deploy and revert model
to a canary model.
And this means that
it can catch problems
early on when it affects only a
slight percentage of the users.
Let's say one team didn't
want to run all of the stages.
Well, they could
simply bypass it.
They could pick
and choose whatever
stages they wanted to run.
And if another team
wanted a person
to approve deploying
to production,
well, they could just inject
a new manual judgment stage
right before the
deployment to production.
Working with paved
road pipelines
means that any
enhancements or fixes
that we want to make
to the pipelines
are immediately reflected
across the entire organization.
And that makes it easy to
make decisions and have
them automated throughout.
There are some important
technical aspects to even.
All of this is done as
code, with code reviews
sent to teammates
before each change
to this paved road system.
So tracking and rolling
back is pretty easy.
We have a few of these
paved roads at Waze.
One is for microservices
and the other
is for our data
layer, Cassandra.
We actually run
blue-green deployments
when upgrading or resizing
our Cassandras fleets.
And we use pipeline
templates and Spinnaker
to manage all of this.
For example, if we want to stand
up a new multi-cloud Cassandra
cluster, all it takes is
writing a tiny config file,
generating the pipeline
templates for them,
and running them in Spinnaker.
Previously, this would have
taken way too much time
and was prone to error.
And now it's fully automatic.
So for us, that's
pretty amazing.
So that's more or less
the end of my story.
Well, the Waze story.
Today I believe that a
new developer at Waze
has complete autonomy and
can focus on what matters,
mainly thanks to Spinnaker.
Waze has recently joined
the development efforts
around Spinnaker.
And we're specifically focused
on adding some SRE concepts,
like service level
objectives and error budgets.
I believe that once Spinnaker
is aware of an error
budget for an application,
some interesting things
can start to happen.
For example, when a service
is almost out of error budget,
the canary system could
automatically run longer
to gain more confidence
in new versions,
or perhaps something that was
previously fully automatic
now has a manual judgment
stage kicking in because
of the error budget.
As happy as we are to be part
of the Spinnaker community,
there wouldn't be a
Spinnaker community
if it weren't for Andy
Glover and his excellent team
at Netflix for
starting this project.
We're lucky to have
Andy here today with us.
Andy.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDY GLOVER: Hey, man.
Thanks a lot.
That was awesome.
So I've got to warn you, my
slides aren't half as cool
as Tom's.
My name's Andy Glover and
I run delivery engineering
at Netflix.
We are the Spinnaker team.
And I do work at Netflix.
And I want to say
thanks to my good friend
Matt who works at Google for
the phenomenal introduction
earlier.
So again, we're very
happy to be here.
So at Netflix, we value speed.
Indeed, speed of innovation
is our competitive advantage.
We firmly believe that
if we aren't fast,
our competitors
certainly will be.
What's more, our members,
you all-- anyone here
a Netflix member?
A few.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
We love you.
And we are firmly
convinced that you all
demand that we move fast.
When's the last
time you got upset
when you ordered
something from Amazon
and it didn't
arrive the same day?
So if we don't move fast,
we're pretty sure that you'll
go to our competitors.
So whether it's to address
a bug, add new features,
or even add new content, you
name it, if we don't move fast
and meet your
expectations, we're
convinced you'll go elsewhere.
We also firmly believe
that the faster we learn,
the faster we
evolve and continue
to win moments of truth.
Netflix is a global company.
Our service is used by more than
130 million people every day.
And we're available in
almost 200 countries.
And to facilitate our growth,
we have a global infrastructure.
We leverage AWS and
operate in multiple regions
around the world.
Moreover, we also leverage a
commercial content delivery
network, as well as our own
fleet of globally distributed
servers for content distribution
called open connect appliances.
So operating at
this level of scale
requires sophisticated
tooling that ultimately
makes it easy for
development teams
to move fast with a high
degree of confidence,
as you saw with Waze.
And so that's why we built a
continuous delivery platform,
or excuse me, a continuous
delivery and infrastructure
management platform, which we
accordingly named Spinnaker.
And the key thing
is Spinnaker was
built leveraging the
myriad lessons learned
from multiple
systems that enabled
continuous delivery at Netflix
over the past number of years.
And so orchestrating
the delivery
of software assets via
Spinnaker facilitates
moving fast at a global scale.
It has accelerated
our time to market.
Spinnaker empowers teams to make
rapid changes with confidence,
and thus enables a focus on
building the right product
for you all.
It has also improved developer
productivity and efficiency.
So yeah, that's my
paved road slide.
Thanks, Tom.
Appreciate it.
[LAUGHS] So yeah,
Spinnaker is a platform
that enables all the benefits
of continuous delivery.
And accordingly, it
acts as a paved road
for making it painless to
take ideas and put them
in front of users rapidly.
This paved road enables
teams at Netflix
to focus on their charters and
not on the nuances of delivery.
So ultimately, Spinnaker makes
developers' lives easier.
And because its an
extensible platform,
Spinnaker provides
a means to plug
into a greater infrastructure
of integrated tools
in other platforms, like
Chaos Monkey, squeeze testing,
which we call Citrus, and
automated canary analysis,
which Tom alluded to
with his awesome slides,
and which I believe there's
going to be a demo as well.
We call it Kayenta.
And so developers
who use Spinnaker,
they get all these tools
for free without having
to write all the glue code to
switch together a complex--
or to, excuse me, stitch
together a complex delivery
process, like people were
doing before Spinnaker.
At Netflix, there aren't
any centralized DevOps teams
or release teams.
Teams at Netflix own
their own destiny,
building their own
pipelines in Spinnaker,
and managing their
apps in production.
They leverage what's available
out of the box in Spinnaker,
but--
and this is key--
they're free to build
on top of Spinnaker,
adding their needs so
as to efficiently reap
the benefits of
continuous delivery.
So the needs of various
teams at Netflix
has resulted in
powerful extensions
within Spinnaker that enable
not only rapid and reliable
delivery to AWS--
anyone here heard of AWS?
Had to sneak that in--
but also to Akamai, which is
a content delivery network,
and to our own container
cloud called Titus.
You can think of it a
lot like Kubernetes.
But the innovations
don't stop there.
Spinnaker has also been
extended to facilitate delivery
of firmware updates to that
fleet of global servers
that I called open
connect appliances, which
are distributed across
the world in data centers
closest to where you live.
So when you actually hit
Play, the video itself is
streamed to you from that
box, not from the cloud,
so to speak, AWS.
Spinnaker enables the safe
manipulation of feature flags.
That is, you can create a
complex delivery pipeline
for changing runtime
data in production
without shooting
yourself in the foot.
And furthermore,
Spinnaker now enables
the delivery and management
of libraries across Netflix.
So you can imagine there
are teams at Netflix that
potentially don't, or
do not, own a service
that facilitates streaming.
They ultimately own a library
And they, too, now
are using Spinnaker
to effect delivery of those
libraries to other teams
and managing those
libraries once they're
in the infrastructure.
As Tom said, Spinnaker
is open source
with a strong and vibrant
community, including Netflix,
Google, or Woogle,
Waze, but also
folks like Target, who's
here at this conference,
my good friends from Pivotal,
Under Armor, Microsoft.
And that's just naming a few of
the large companies investing
in this platform.
Everyone is innovating
within the platform.
So not only does Spinnaker
integrate with major cloud
vendors, but there are
integrations with OpenStack,
Pivotal Cloud Foundry, DCOS, and
even Oracle Bare Metal Cloud.
What's more, the community is
building new pipeline stages,
command line tools for
interacting with and managing
Spinnaker, and even new
Kayenta metric sources,
like Stackdriver and Datadog.
This will all make
more sense once you see
the demo of canary analysis.
And that's just some
of the innovations
that this community is building
within the Spinnaker ecosystem.
And so I think all of
us within the community
would agree that rapid and
reliable global software
delivery has never been
more easy than it is today.
And with that, I will turn it
over to my good friend Matt
from Google.
[APPLAUSE]
MATT DUFTLER: Thanks, Andy.
And thanks, Tom, for setting
the bar so high for animations
and slides that none of
us will ever measure up.
All right, so Tom
mentioned earlier
that Spinnaker enables
his development teams
to push changes into
production with confidence.
And I gather he has
some kind of confidence,
because he's going
to allow me to push
a change live into the
production environment at Waze.
So if I could have the
demo laptop, please.
All right, so we'll
kick this off.
We'll let it run
in the background,
and then we'll
come back and talk
about exactly what's going on.
So cross your fingers
for the demo gods.
We'll let that go.
And if I could have the
presentation laptop again.
The one with the slides.
The other one with the slides.
Thanks.
All right, so it's
going to push a change.
The idea here is that
we'll let it work.
It'll take maybe
10 minutes or so.
We'll come back and poke
around the configuration
and the execution
of that pipeline.
It's a live change against Waze.
Any of you planning
on skipping out
early, bad time to use Waze
to get out of San Francisco.
But that's on you.
All right, so in the past,
Google's disclosed many numbers
about our internal
source control system.
And these are
incredible numbers.
My data is out of
date, but things
like over a billion
files, tens of millions
of commits, tens of
thousands of software
developers, all working out
of the same giant repository.
I want to talk about a
different set of numbers now.
The goal here is not
really to leave you
with an impression about
Google's internal scale
or complexity, but more
about just our commitment
to the Spinnaker project and
the surrounding community.
So I'm part of the
Spinnaker team.
We work full time on Spinnaker.
In the last year or so, we've
more than doubled in size.
We have 13 full time software
engineers, full time product
manager, a technical
program manager,
and a dedicated
engineering manager.
He brought stickers.
He's around here somewhere.
What we're doing, these are
some of the things we work on.
We support customers and users.
Not all of the users we work
with are Google customers.
Many are, but not all.
We're in the Slack channel all
the time just helping people.
It's good for the community
and it's good for us,
because we find out what
people are interested in
and what's important
to the company.
So it lets us focus.
We built out a large
release workflow
for building, testing, and
releasing Spinnaker itself.
The project is 9, 10,
11, I don't know how many
independent microservices.
It's a big, complicated project.
Before we built this
release workflow,
folks were pretty much
just running it at head.
Clone all the repos, figure
out how to configure it,
fight YAML, run it,
ask questions on Slack.
We built out a process to do
regularly scheduled integration
tests and have
versioned releases
across all these
independent services,
including change logs, pegging
changes to future versions,
and so on.
The goal there was to
really make it easier
to install and manage.
And we'll talk more
about that in a second.
But also to give
confidence to enterprises
that it's a real project,
real product, has a version.
You can count on it.
We'll release patch releases
when important things
are discovered and so on.
On the topic of installing and
configuring Spinnaker, it's--
well, the idea is that
you can install it,
you can get it running.
And then when you have
an issue, in the past,
we had to go and say, try this
YAML file, make this change,
and so on.
So we built a tool to make
that easier called Halyard.
We'll talk more about
that in a second,
but I think it's a pretty
good example of something
we built entirely out in the
open in the open source that
makes everybody's lives
working with Spinnaker quite
a bit easier.
We also work on internal
usage of Spinnaker.
There's some Google
teams pushing
changes, an internal Google
infrastructure using Spinnaker.
And we'll talk more about that
in the coming months as well.
So the obvious question--
well, not who is
that, because that's
somebody who works at
Waze, because I've seen him
when I visited, but why?
Why such an investment
in the Spinnaker project?
So there are lots of reasons.
The first is that there are
primitives in operations
that Spinnaker defines,
align really, really
well with our internal
best practices.
Things that folks do on internal
proprietary Google systems
match up perfectly well
with what Spinnaker
is bringing to the community.
Another good reason
for us, convergence.
Whether it's open
source software, state
of the art software
like Spinnaker,
or our various cloud
offerings that GCP is offering
to customers, the more
we can align those things
with what we do internally,
the better for customers,
the better for hiring new
folks at Google, and so on.
It's an all around good thing.
Tom talked a bit
about abstractions.
The idea with Spinnaker
isn't that it creates
perfect abstractions over every
underlying cloud platform,
but that it creates
a commonality,
so you have a
consistent experience.
It's just consistent enough
that you can find your way,
and hopefully, each
development team
doesn't have to become an
expert on every cloud platform
that they're targeting.
The operations themselves
are abstractions for, and it
does help you get out
of the weeds in terms
of baking images, and pushing
new versions of your software
out into production, doing
rollbacks, managing traffic,
running canaries.
All of these things are defined
as first class primitives,
and they let you think at
a slightly higher level,
rather than fighting
every nuance and detail
of the underlying platforms.
Lastly, Google's tied at the
hip with open source software.
We contribute to tons
of open source projects.
We use open source
software ourselves
throughout the Google stack.
So it's everywhere.
Spinnaker is really just
one more example of Google
being part of the broader
open source community.
So in terms of Google's
involvement with Spinnaker,
it started maybe four or so
years ago, late summer 2014.
One person working part time on
the project as a 20% project.
And it took off from there.
We started off with
adding support for GCE,
and then Kubernetes, and GKE,
and App Engine, and so on.
And as each platform
becomes available,
we've continued to add support.
And then we've given a lot
of that back to the community
by helping other
folks, some of whom
look like competitors,
some are competitors,
but we're all kind of working
together out in the open
and sharing what we all
know about adding support
for additional platforms.
And that's been
pretty rewarding.
So I wrote make it easy
to install and manage.
And I remembered there's
going to be a video,
and I crossed it out
and I wrote easier.
It's not easy, but
it's hopefully easier.
This is Halyard that I was
describing a moment ago.
It's much better than it was.
It's definitely easier.
It's not simple.
It's a big, complicated thing.
That's just all there is to it.
The types of organizations
that adopt Spinnaker
are large organizations,
typically,
maybe serving multiple teams
across multiple projects,
multiple cloud
platforms, with lots
of complexity and variability.
And that requires a pretty
sophisticated platform.
Spinnaker itself has all
these individual services
that can each horizontally
scale as they need to,
and they all kind of cooperate
to produce this platform.
So it's not trivial
to install or manage.
But Halyard lets you
do it, lets you do it
on VMs, on containers, in an
atomic fashion or a distributed
fashion, handles no
downtime upgrades,
and flipping every option on and
off, and everything in between.
And I wrote advanced topics.
I wasn't sure what to
call it, but the idea here
is that beyond
sort of making sure
all the table stakes are there
to make enterprises happy.
We work on a lot
of things that I
would describe as adding in
best practices and smarts
into the platform.
Just as we learn
things over time,
we try to build more
and more of that
in so companies can
adopt this, encourage
their own teams to
follow best practices,
but also share back what we've
learned so not everybody has
to create a canary analysis
service from scratch, which
is what we're going
to talk about next.
So this is Kayenta.
Think Andy mentioned it.
It's an automated
canary analysis service.
That's a mouthful.
It's a recently released
Spinnaker service.
We partnered with another
team at Netflix, part of which
is now, I think, part
of the Spinnaker team
proper at Netflix--
DET team, Delivery
Engineering Team at Netflix.
So we partnered to take
a service that they've
been running for
many years inside
of Netflix, which was like
battle-hardened through quite
a bit of adoption there, called
ACA, and kind of reimagine it
and evolve it to be a bit
more open and extensible
and support a broader
set of use cases.
And that's what Kayenta is.
And we did it with the
team that have been working
on that service all along.
It was open sourced
a few months back.
Some of the key things we wanted
to accomplish out of the gate
were to make sure
that it supports
all of the cloud platforms
that Spinnaker itself supports.
So it's not geared towards any
one platform in particular.
So right out of
the gate, the day
it was released, it
could be used with GCE,
with AWS, with Kubernetes,
every other supported platform.
It doesn't really have an
opinion about the underlying
platform.
In addition, it supports
an extensible set
of metrics services.
So we released it as
support for Stackdriver,
with support for Atlas, which
is Netflix's own time series
database, support for
Prometheus, the Armory folks.
I saw some of them
bouncing around.
Added support for Datadog.
A community member added
support for Influx DB right
after it was released.
So it's a growing set of
metric services it supports.
All the way up through
UI integration.
It's pretty cool to work with.
And we'll see some
of that in a moment.
Lastly, pluggable canary judges.
The initially supported judge
is the one that was in use
at Netflix, is still in use.
I think it's just
called the ACA judge,
but we can call it
the Netflix judge.
There are other
judges in development.
Google has some
judges internally
that we're working
on integrating.
But the idea is it's
extensible and people
can do what makes sense there.
You're not stuck to one
particular approach.
So this is going to
be-- it's kind of quick,
and it's just really a taste
of what Kayenta offers.
We think it's a very good
example of the kinds of things
we're doing, really,
to push the envelope
in the continuous
delivery space.
There are webinars
and things that we've
done that you can find online
for more details about Kayenta.
All right, so this brings
us back to the pipeline.
So what that pipeline does, and
we'll look at it in a second,
it orchestrates a canary
release for a particular Waze
service when a new
image becomes available.
The idea with
canarying changes is
that it really should be
used for any kind of change.
It can be a binary change,
like a new image is available.
It can be a config change,
an infrastructure change.
But the bottom line is
you have some change you
want to make against something
running in production,
and you want to do
it in a safe way.
You want to determine
in an automated
of a fashion as possible whether
it's a safe change or not.
And you want to make sure
to have a very narrow blast
radius.
And then over time, as you gain
confidence in that release,
you roll it out to a
broader and broader scope.
So this particular one is
just a new binary image
becoming available.
This is the service
that it affects.
It's a Waze text
to speech service.
It generates real
time audio when you're
using Waze for navigation.
It's a global service.
It's available behind a global
load balancer, an HTTPS load
balancer.
It's requested miles in advance.
So hopefully, no Waze
users were harmed
in the making of this demo.
But it's not really sensitive
to latency because it
happens way in advance.
What we're doing here is we took
the running production image
and we changed it.
And we changed it to
artificially introduce
some latency into the backend.
So the load balancer that's
forwarding traffic to all
of these individual
backends is also
reporting to Stackdriver metrics
on things like backend latency.
And in this case,
we artificially
increase that latency,
so the metrics
that are recorded
in Stackdriver are
going to show a higher number
for that particular metric.
And then we configured an
extremely simple canary
analysis that looks at just
that one backend latency metric
and tries to determine, with
some automated statistical
tests, whether there's a
significant difference there.
And this is the basic path
of automated canary analysis.
You find the strong
indicators of safety
for your particular use
case, your application.
You configure the
canary analysis
to look those things up.
You make sure they're being
published from your application
and your infrastructure.
And then you apply, at runtime,
the statistical techniques,
which we can talk more about.
And then a scoring
strategy is applied.
And it's compared to thresholds
that you define for your use
case, your pipelines.
And then it's treated as a
gate for that deployment, OK?
In this case, it's
a trivial example.
While it's running against
live systems, we gave it,
I don't know, six
minutes to warm up
and four minutes of runtime.
So we're going to get four
one-minute data points.
It's a very small set of data.
It's just for demonstration.
In experimenting
with it, we ended up
turning up the sensitivity
of the judge a bit,
because the judge
would basically say,
this isn't really enough data
to have a lot of confidence.
So we said, well, we still
want to have an answer.
If I could have the
demo laptop, please.
All right, so it should
finish in about 10 seconds.
We'll look at the configuration
of this while we wait.
So this is a pretty typical
pipeline with a canary release.
What we encourage
for best practices
when you're configuring
your own canary
is don't provision the
new canary resources
and compare it to
everything else that's
already been running
in production
for some period of time.
Provision a new set
of resources using
what's running in production
as a baseline and a sibling
using the canary configuration.
So it's a very apples
to apples comparison.
Use the same infrastructure,
provision them
at the same point in time.
And the single only
delta should be
the change you want to canary.
In this case, it's
a new binary image.
So that's why you see here
there are a couple of lookups.
So find the baseline image,
find the canary image.
And we're just using
tag-based lookups to say,
what's running in
production, what's
the new image that's
available, what's
the change we want to canary?
Then we deploy a new baseline
and a new canary in parallel.
And then we have the
canary analysis stage.
And the way Spinnaker
works, each of these stages
completes before the next one.
It's quite standard
control flow.
You can see the control
flow joins back together
at the canary analysis stage.
The only thing worth
keeping in mind
here is you have
these two deploys.
These are provisioning.
Here we're running on GCE VMs.
It works the same on whatever
platform, but in this case,
these are GCE VMs running
in managed instance groups.
Those stages won't be
considered complete
until they're
considered healthy based
on a number of things-- load
balancers, machine health,
and so on.
So the canary analysis
is quite straightforward.
In this case, it's a
real time analysis,
which means we're waiting
for metrics to be published,
collected.
You can do a retrospective
analysis as well.
We refer to a config
and think of that
as like a templated query.
That's also done through the UI.
I don't think we're
going to show that now.
And then you can see
a warm-up period.
And you can
configure a lifetime.
And you can break it down into
multiple intervals and so on.
And below that, it says,
what's the pair of things
I want to compare?
And in this case,
we're comparing
a baseline and a
canary server group
that were just provisioned--
I'll make a little bigger--
that we're just
provisioned upstream.
And then there's some additional
configuration for the query.
So when this thing runs--
the canary gods smiled upon us.
So this failed, which
is what we wanted.
You can see it
says, canary score
is not above the
marginal score threshold.
And it does-- you can see
this little red triangle.
It's admonishing us
that we probably,
if we're going to rely
on this for production,
want to have more
data points than that.
We'll see in a moment, but I'm
sure we have three or four data
points.
So this is-- back
out little bit.
This is what a standard
set of execution details
look like for a
Spinnaker pipeline.
In this case, it's
that canary stage.
But you can see
the configuration,
which said, what
are we comparing,
what's the warm up period,
how long does the canary run?
And then the individual--
the statuses of the
individual tasks
that make up that canary stage.
And this is, I think,
a pretty decent example
of what you would
have to do if you
wanted to script this by hand.
You have to do
this provisioning.
You have to configure
this thing to wait
for some period of time.
You have to make sure
things are healthy.
Then you have to run the
actual analysis, which
means go off, build
queries, fetch the metrics,
figure out how to compare them.
You can probably find
off-the-shelf statistical
tests.
And you could probably
make all of that work.
But the idea with Spinnaker is
to make all of that consumable.
I mean, we're trying
to kind of let
you work with a higher
level of primitive.
And the canary analysis is
the latest example of that.
So this completed.
If we look at the results,
we can drill down.
And now this is one metric.
It's very simple.
So the graph is
also quite simple.
But you can see on the left,
the name of that metric.
You can see that the
classification logic determined
it to be high, so the
canary was high with respect
to the baseline.
In this case, the only score
we possibly could have gotten
is 0 or 100, because we
only have the one metric,
so you can't use any
weighted scoring or anything.
And then you can see
the two lines across.
Hopefully, you can see the
two lines across the graph.
The canary is blue
and the baseline
is maybe golden axelrod.
I don't know what color that is.
But you have the
two lines there.
And then at the
bottom, there are
some simple statistical details.
And you can see it said it got
three data points for each.
And the nice thing about
the way we surface this
is that everything is available.
So you can actually drill
down right from the UI.
And you can see the
resulting queries
that were expanded and
executed, in this case,
against Stackdriver.
But it works the same no
matter the underlying system.
So you can see the metric.
You can see the queries.
And you can see the
actual data points that
were returned from Stackdriver.
All right, if I could have
the slides laptop again.
Don't need the video.
All right, so what's next?
I think we've given a
pretty good example of where
we are now.
And we wanted to
talk about what's
coming in the coming months.
The Spinnaker community itself
is pretty warm and welcoming.
And like I said, tons
of folks are always
in the Slack channel,
always willing to help.
But the code base itself is
still kind of like a tough nut
to crack.
So we want to figure out how to
make it easier for other folks
to get involved.
We've lately been writing
more developer guides
and we're hosting workshops.
And this is we, the whole
community, not just Google.
But this is one
of the main things
we're focused on at the moment.
Also, to really formalize some
of our processes and procedures
in terms of how the
Spinnaker community operates
and how people can
become committers
and those kinds of things.
The set of cloud platforms
is always continuing to grow.
There's support for
this thing called
artifacts, which is the idea
of instead of embedding logic
deep within Spinnaker
to understand
what comes from Jenkins, or
what comes from a container
registry, externalize
that information.
So an artifact would
say, this type of thing
from this location with this
address and this metadata.
So we call that artifacts.
But we're making
that more consumable
and adding support for
additional systems.
The canary stage that we showed
had upstream deployment stages,
and then later on,
those things you
provisioned to do the comparison
have to be cleaned up.
We're adding support directly
into the canary stage
for doing that orchestration
to make it easier
to configure canary releases.
There's a CLI which, at present,
lets you programmatically
publish and interact
with pipelines.
We're broadening the set
of capabilities of the CLI.
There's work underway
inside of Netflix
for the time being to add
support for a SQL backend
as an alternative for in-flight
workflow representation,
provide more durability and
some other capabilities.
And there are several streams
of work underway involving
configuration as code, from
manifest oriented deployments
to approaches where you
declare the desired state,
and then it's constantly
trying to achieve
that state on some schedule, and
a bunch of other related bits.
And just think of it
as a spectrum from I
do everything with a UI and
a wizard and fill in fields,
or I check in my
manifest somewhere.
And then whether it's a
source control system,
or some system that
supports buckets.
And then Spinnaker tries
to achieve that state.
All right, best is yet to come.
In terms of getting
involved, we have a site
that has tons of information.
There are code labs,
tutorials, there's
documentation,
reference architectures.
There's all kinds of
information up there.
We have the Slack channel where
there's-- there are people
in there 24 hours a day, always
willing to answer questions.
There's a discourse
community forum.
There are I don't know
how many GitHub repos,
but that's the umbrella repo.
That's where to start.
That's where most of
the issues are tracked,
so that's a good starting point.
And I don't want
to forget, we're
having a summit in
October in Seattle.
Looks like it's
going to be huge.
Come join us.
It's open.
It's not just for folks
who are already involved
in the Spinnaker community.
It's for people who
want to get involved,
whether as developers, or users,
or partners, or anything else.
So please come join us.
[MUSIC PLAYING]